Hospital health IT systems came into
widespread use in the late 1970s and
80s.
There were some early attempts
to provide a single vendor
fully integrated hospital wide solution,
but most systems were developed for
a particular department, such as
pharmacy, clinical lab, or radiology.
And it was common for each of these
departments to select their own system.
As a result,
hospitals were faced with the problem
of communicating among those systems.
So, for example, patients could
be uniformly registered and
charges could be reliably collected.
Health level seven, HL7, evolved to
create these messaging standards.
It used EDIX12 to format the messages.
Its latest version, 3, migrates to XML,
which, as we discussed earlier,
is a technology developed for
the internet in which tags and
HTML formats are used to described
data elements within web pages.
While it is more verbose, memory and
disk space are now inexpensive.
It is more human readable, and
of course, still machine readable, and
it's easily rendered in a browser.